Given these requirements,
cloud computing provides the following.
First, a pool of shared resources.
These can come in as infrastructure,
compute storage networking.
That doesn't mean that
the cloud provider like Amazon,
is renting out physical machines,
or physical disks.
But instead that it's
renting out virtual machines
that are even potentially interconnected
to form some virtual clusters of such
[INAUDIBLE] along with some ability
to store some amount of state
in the underlying storage.
Cloud computing can also come in as
shared resources that are used by
higher level software services,
so these are soft resources.
For instance, this can correspond to
certain popular services like email or
database or some processing run times.
So it may be easier to just rent all the
infrastructure along with the software
stack that's appropriately configured,
as opposed to, as a customer, to come in
and rent actual infrastructure and then
deal with the deployment of the service,
the configuration and
the management of the service.
So both of these are options in terms of
what it is that cloud computing
provides as a resource.
These infrastructure software resources
are all made available via some APIs for
access and configuration.
The point is that they
need to be accessed and
manipulated as necessary remotely,
over the internet.
This typically includes web-based APIs,
also APIs that are wrapped in
libraries that can be integrated in
popular language runtimes like Java, or
command line interfaces,
or other types of tools.
Providers offer many different types
of billing and accounting services.
There is an entire marketplace
surrounding these cloud services and
cloud resources that includes
pricing models with spot prices or
reservations for future prices or
other types of models.
One common characteristic is that
billing is typically not done based on
actual usage.
Just because the overheads
that are associated with
ultra fine grain monitoring and
management tend to be pretty high, and
instead billing is done based
on some discreet step function.
For instance, computer resources may
come in some number of preconfigured
alternatives, like tiny and
medium and large and
extra large and each of these
will have a different cost.
So, then the user picks which one
of these matches their needs and
then pays the corresponding
grade when using the VM.
And all of this, finally,
is managed by the cloud provider via
some sophisticated software stack.
Common software stacks that
are used in this space include
the Open Source OpenStack and also
the VMWare's vSphere software stack.